Hey youtubers it's Charlie and I had a chance
to go to the Night Before Our Stars event
for TFIOS so this is going to be my review
of the movie. If you've never heard of it
before it's a young adult drama based on a
novel by one half of vlogbrothers, John Green.
I assure you it is an endurance test of your
ability to not cry. Which is part of the reason
I was really excited to see it with so many
superfans.
Because a lot of you probably haven't seen
it yet I'm going to do my non spoilery review
as well as talk about the Night Before Our
Stars and then I'll give a spoiler warning
and do my top 5 moments and a breakdown of
all the differences between the movie and
the book for any of you that are book readers.
If you're finding me for the first time I'm
doing summer movie reviews every week. Next
up is How to Train Your Dragon 2 and Transformers.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything and
feel free to leave me suggestions for other
movies in the comments.
So first off, The Night Before Our Stars was
a special preview screening and Q&A session
with Shailene Woodley, Ansel Elgort, John
Green and bunch of other people from the movie.
They did it in theaters all over the world
and just broadcast the Q&A to all the places
at the same time.
If you're a fellow nerdfighter then you'll
be pleased to know that they showed John Green's
cameo in the film. It got cut for time and
even though he said he was happy they cut
it out of the movie. All of nerdfighteria
will really enjoy it when the dvd comes out.
The place I went to was understandably mostly
teenage women and families but it was a very
different experience from the time I saw that
last Twilight movie in a theater. That time
it was pretty much all women too, but instead
of everyone crying everyone was laughing.
At Twilight, not at TFIOS. Although the Fault
In Our Stars had some really funny moments.
It's a really good movie to go see if you're
1 not afraid to cry and 2 want a really deep
emotional experience that you might not get
at a big effects driven action movie. And
3, it's always fun to watch a movie about
a book you really love. Just to watch it unfold
in front of your eyes.
I caution you, if you are a huge fan of the
book you're eyes will either burn out of their
sockets from all the excitement or melt from
all the tears.
One of my favorite things about the movie
was that it's totally upfront about what it
is. A young adult cancer drama intended to
yank on your heartstrings and ask the question,
what happens to the people you leave behind.
But it gets there in a very authentic way.
I kept having to squish old feelings the movie
reminded me of when I was around 16 to 18.
I guess if you wanted to explain the story
to someone in an even simpler way you could
just say "pain demands to be felt"
I'm pretty good at keeping feels deep down
inside, but if you ever wanted to be a part
of a giant group of people all feeling the
same thing. This will be the best movie you
go see all summer.
For all the book readers out there I'll talk
more about specific stuff the movie changed
during spoilers in case you want to wait till
you see it.
But even if you don't consider yourself a
nerdfighter DFTA and go see this movie. This
will go down as the highest grossing movie
originated by a youtuber. And the community
of nerdfighters is a big reason why everyone
knows about this film. I won't make any comparisons,
because it wasn't like any other movie I've
seen in the last year. And that's a very good
thing.
So now I'm going to movie into spoilers and
talk about my Top 5 Moments and all the changes
from the book. So careful if you haven't seen
it yet. Here we go.
Number 5 - Augustus Passionately Defends Price
of Dawn
This reminded me of every time I tried to
convince my girlfriends over the years to
watch Star Wars or Lord of The Rings. I was
also a huge fan of the Dragonlance books in
Middle School which is kind of like a Dungeons
and Dragons series of novels. I was never
quite as articulate as Augustus. He really
knows how to sell a book, regardless of what
it's about.
Number 4 - Willem Dafoe as Van Houten
He was awful and funny at the same time. Which
was totally on purpose, the character is so
terrible all you can do is laugh at him. Especially
when he jumped in Hazel's car at the funeral.
Be sure to let me know in the comments if
you ever listened to Swedish Hip Hop after
reading the book or seeing the movie.
Remember, it's not important what they're
saying, it's what they're feeling.
Number 3 - Hazel and Augustus's Talk While
Isaac Smashes Stuff
I laughed a lot while all this was going on,
mostly because Augustus has this unbroken
attention on Hazel and their conversation
about An Imperial Affliction and you see Hazel's
eyes dart back and forth between trophy smashing
and Augustus. Like she's surprised both by
Isaac going crazy and the fact that Augustus
is totally able to ignore it.
Just on a technical level I can't imagine
how hard it must have been for the actors
to do that scene and remember all their lines.
It would be like having two conversations
at the same time and remembering everything
without messing up.
Number 2 - The Birth of the Okays
That whole initial text montage and the way
the movie visually showed their texts was
really cool. But I feel like the okays were
one of the most important parts of the story.
Like that was like the real moment they became
bonded as a couple. I thought that was way
more meaningful and emotional than when they
actually had sex.
But let me know what moment you think they
became an actual couple.
and my Number 1 Moment - The Dinner in Amsterdam
I felt like this was the real climax of the
movie. Because up to this point Hazel finally
gotten over her grenade fears and just let
herself be in love with Augustus who is just
on fire. Ansel Elgort really did bring it.
The really intimate way they filmed the restaurant
scene just made that whole dinner feel like
they were floating in heaven. And I liked
that they used the lights on the tree as a
visual metaphor for the title. I don't think
Dom Perignon tastes like stars but in that
moment in space and time it totally felt like
it did.
But now it's your turn, let me know in the
comments what your favorite moment was?
As promised, here are all the things I could
find that were different from the book. Feel
free to add more if you saw something I missed.
They didn't do the phone number in the book,
instead Hazel just waits for him to call.
They didn't do the V for Vendetta scene where
she puts her hand out and he doesn't try to
hold it. They did the should I go in for a
kiss double take.
Kaitlin and Hazel don't go shopping
Hazel never peeps on Augustus' ex girlfriend
Hazel didn't read Van Houten's letter in the
hospital
They don't write a swing set advertisement,
"Lonely Vaugely Pedophilic swing set seeks
the butts of children."
Hazel and Isaac don't play video games together
Augustus never fights with his family before
going to Amsterdam
When they're on the boat tour of Amsterdam
people don't yell how beautiful they look
They didn't drink Champagne on the flight
Augustus and Hazel's families don't have dinner
together
We don't meet Augustus' extended family
And Hazel never got upset with all the condolences
messages from people after Gus dies
And also, instead of Divergent being on Hazel's
shelf they had Hunger Games because Shailene
Woodley thought it would be too weird.
So like I said, even if you're not a nerdfighter.
DFTBA and go see this movie. Then let me know
what you thought.
My next movie review will be for How To Train
Your Dragon 2. Be sure to subscribe to get
it. I'm getting ready to hit 250,000 subscribers
and I'm trying to time it so that I post a
Doctor Who video right as I cross the line.
That's happening tomorrow.
Right now click here to learn about Emily
Blunt becoming the new Catwoman or maybe Miss
Marvel and click here to learn why I think
Benedict Cumberbatch needs to be Doctor Strange
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives okay okay!